[Music]
not exactly sure what you mean oh
retainer
[Music]
[Applause]
retainer
do you want us to give you cash right
now
oh I don't think I I can uh Larry I've
got uh 73 dollars will you take a
chatter bingo
hey what's going on everybody I'm Dave
Rubin this is the Reuben report it is
June 20th 2023. holy cow I say it almost
every day but this year is just freaking
flying by so fast I cannot believe we
are more than halfway done with the year
but here we are uh as always we are live
streaming on Rumble locals and YouTube
subscribe and tap that notification Bell
if you have not uh and I want to give a
special welcome to all our new uh
subscribers over at locals uh we did a
big push over the last couple days and
got a couple hundred new people very
excited to have you guys on board we
will not let you down and you can live
chat during the show right now at
reubenreport.locals.com and by the way
as of today we are relaunching the
Reuben report merch store which is at
daverubin dot store you can get the make
America Florida shirt we have a funny
LGBT shirt it doesn't mean the usual LGB
PT stuff Reuben report things things
involving Clyde and all sorts of other
fun things and uh yeah there's all sorts
of stuff that you can get a picture with
me with one of my
go to slogans you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
people and I have to say the soft and it
flows on you nicely very exciting we've
got defund the IRS shirts and much more
uh speaking of the government these big
institutions doing a whole bunch of crap
there is some breaking news happening
right this moment which sort of sounds
good but I have a feeling it's actually
not good uh this is from Greg price uh
breaking Hunter Biden has been charged
with two tax misdemeanors and illegal
possession of a firearm pleading guilty
to the first two and entering into a
pre-trial diversion agreement on the
ladder which will undoubtedly keep him
out of jail
so I just want to address this real
quick I was actually supposed to be on
Fox news this morning I was doing Dana
Perino and Bill hemmer's show I was
supposed to be talking about DeSantis
and Newsome but then the press
conference on this thing broke so they
had me commented on it on the Fly and
I'll just basically real quick repeat
what I said there which is this sort of
on on its face value sounds good like
they're finally going after Hunter a
little bit uh but if you think about it
a little bit further and this is what
you have to do with almost everything
these days there's the headline and then
there's what what's right beneath it uh
this sort of feels like this is how
they're going to get Hunter Biden and
thus Joe Biden to run away scot-free
right so they're not looking into all of
the money that he got and the barisma
deal and the five million dollar wire
and all the stuff that's the real stuff
uh they're getting him on some random
stuff but he's already cut the plea deal
and sounds like we'll automatically stay
out of prison so we shall see but again
the asymmetry of everything is what is
driving people crazy we have to have one
standard of law was for everybody and
you cannot have Democrat privilege you
guys know about Democrat privilege
you're allowed to ruin everything as a
as a public servant and you get uh you
know you usually get a better job Gavin
Newsom right through in San Francisco as
mayor becomes governor of California on
his way to trying to become president or
you just skate by the legal system where
if you're a republican they're going to
look at you uh very in a much more
focused way uh one other thing and then
I will tell you the theme of today's
show I promise you this is actually very
cool and it's directly related uh to
what we talked about yesterday first
I'll show you a tweet from NBC and then
the cool thing this was NBC News
yesterday YouTube says it has removed a
video of Robert F Kennedy Jr speaking
with podcast host Jordan Peterson for
spreading what the company says is
vaccine misinformation now first off
that they Whittle Jordan down to podcast
host is whatever is what it is but on
the heels of that so Jordan interviewed
Robert F Kennedy I think was about an
hour and a half long interview I saw a
little clip of it
YouTube took it down I don't know if
Jordan's Channel got a strike uh we've
discussed the strike situation with you
if your channel gets a strike you can't
live stream for a little while you get
two strikes then you can't live stream
for like a month you get three strikes
and you're gone so this is a real threat
it's assault absolutely on free speech
and if you think that Jordan Peterson
and Robert F Kennedy is too scary to be
on YouTube we got a real freaking
problem and yes we do have a real
frequent problem but good things are
happening people look at this from
Rumble this morning I had an inkling
this was gonna happen yesterday breaking
Rumble welcomes Robert F Kennedy Jr
Democrat candidate for president Robert
F Kennedy Junior's first live stream
will take place at 7 pm eastern time
this evening that's right so look the
more they attack us the more the
machines come after us and chase us down
and all of that stuff we will continue
to build new institutions with what
we're doing at Rumble what we're doing
at locals what elon's doing at Twitter
there are alternative roads the parallel
economy the the Free Speech Internet
it's being built it does exist and we're
just going to keep fighting it and I
appreciate that you're on the journey
with us uh Today's Show now we can get
to the theme uh today's show is going to
be framed around this really I don't
know any other adjective to say other
than disastrous interview that President
Trump did with Brett Bear on Fox last
night it was really really bizarre I
don't know how again regardless of what
side of the Trump DeSantis thing you're
on or anything else I don't know how
Trump's lawyers let him do this you
could see why some of his lawyers are
quitting and why he's having trouble
surrounding himself with good people
because he goes and does these
interviews and says crazy things in the
midst of legal cases right two
indictments and another one coming from
Georgia down the way so we're going to
contrast a bit of Trump's interview a
bunch of Clips we're going to show you
unedited and then we're going to show to
contrast that with an interview that Ron
DeSantis did a couple days ago and you
can just look at the at the fundamental
difference I would say between
discipline and vision for this country
and I think it is a fairly obvious and
then of course we'll go into a little
bit about how the media is treating both
of these guys and the absolute
apoplectic spasming that the corporate
press is doing about Ron DeSantis and
Casey to say this right now it's just so
insane and it's like man we've seen this
movie before but a certain amount of
people just fall for it over and over
again before we get to that let me talk
to you guys about Birch gold group you
guys know that Congress once again
allowed itself to be pushed into
appeasing the administration and raise
the debt ceiling for the 79th time
Paving the way for continued Reckless
spending and further devaluation of the
dollar as our national debt continues to
Skyrocket how are you protecting your
savings
Times Like These are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold and you can do that with the help
of Birch gold here's the easiest way to
do it Birch gold will help you convert
an existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in
Gold you don't pay a penny out of pocket
as bricks that's Brazil Russia India
China and South Africa band together
against the dollar more and more central
banks are diversifying you know what
they're buying you got it gold follow
their lead visit birchgold.com Dave for
your free info kit on gold there's no
obligation just information with an A
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau and thousands of happy customers
Birch gold can help protect your savings
too visit birchgold.com Dave do it take
action today okay so former president
Donald Trump in the midst of this
federal case plus the New York case
decided to sit down with Fox news's
Brett Bear last night now most people I
think this is fair to say I welcome your
thoughts in the comments most people
think Brett Bear is a fairly decent
journalist like a fairly decent guy I'm
sure people have their criticisms of
them okay people have their criticisms
with everybody but he's a pretty pretty
pretty middle of the road guy doesn't
seem like he has a major agenda
he sat down with Trump last night and it
was wild it really was wild I mean this
this almost feels like it could end
Trump altogether take a look
okay in 2016 you said that I'm going to
surround myself with only the best and
most serious people well I did do that
this is a tremendous look we had the
best economy we've ever had this time
has ever seen your vice president Mike
Pence is running against you yeah your
ambassador to the United Nations Nikki
Haley she's running against you your
former Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
said he's not supporting you you
mentioned National Security adviser John
Bolton he's not supporting you either
you mentioned attorney general Bill Barr
uh says you shouldn't be president again
uh calls you the consonant narcissist
and troubled man you recently called and
uh bore a gutless pig your second
defense secretary is not supporting you
called you irresponsible this week you
and your White House called your white
house chief of staff John Kelly weak and
ineffective and born with a very small
brain you called your acting white house
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney a born
loser you called your first Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson dumb as a rock and
your first defense secretary James
Mattis the world's most overrated
General you called your White House
secretary Kayla can any milk toast and
multiple times you've referred to your
transportation secretary Elaine Chao as
Mitch McConnell's China loving wife so
why did you hire all of them in the
first place Connor goes to be in the
middle of that thing what do you say
about me in Phoenix when we're not
around I mean look guys that is damning
I know there is a certain set of people
that no matter what Trump does no matter
what Trump says etc etc
they're never going to turn right
they're never gonna see that maybe
something's not right here but he just
went through a freaking laundry list of
not just random people not just you know
the intern and the janitor who don't
like them anymore like this is pretty
much everybody and also the way Trump
looked down when he said what was it he
called uh Bill Barr a gutless pig or
something and the way he said that to
Trump and Trump immediately like he
knows this stuff isn't true so you can
either believe I suppose that Donald
Trump is the greatest human being in the
history of the world ordained by God and
given to us to save all of us
and the rest of these people are all
idiots and morons or some of the worst
stuff that Trump said or that maybe
something's not quite right here that is
not to say that we didn't have a great
economy before covet under Trump we did
that is not to say he didn't make a
whole bunch of good things happen in the
Middle East
and a series of other things that we all
know and I talk about all the time and
it's why I supported him for re-election
but we have to I think decide like do we
want more of this name calling you know
Trump went on later to talk about how uh
there's so many of his people his former
people still do support him but where
are they who are they I know there's
Rick Grinnell and I like Rick and we're
friends uh but who else that was working
under this guy you know after what he
said about Kaylee and the rest of them
that does tell you a little something
but but let's just uh continue for a
moment I want to show you this is video
of the person that Trump made his joint
Chief of Staff this is uh Mark milley
take a look
I want to understand white rage and I'm
white and I want to understand it so
what is it that caused thousands of
people to assault this building and try
to overturn the Constitution of the
United States of America what caused
that I want to find that out I want to
maintain an open mind here and I do want
to analyze it it's important that we
understand that because our soul to
Sailors Airmen Marines and Guardians
they come from the American people so it
is important that the leaders now end in
the future do understand it I've read
miles say Tung I've read I've read Karl
Marx I've read Lenin that doesn't make
me a communist so what is wrong with
understanding having some situational
understanding about the country for
which we are here to defend and I
personally find it offensive that we are
accusing the United States military our
general officers our commissioned
non-commissioned officers of being quote
woke or something else because we're
studying yeah I mean he's completely
wrong and in this case the guy that they
showed there Matt Gates congressman from
Florida you've seen him on the show you
know him uh was completely right calling
the military woke we know that they are
pushing all of this gender stuff and
they are pushing all of the woke racism
stuff we know it's going through the
military so he gets up there and he does
what the lefties do right I'm outraged
that you would even ask me this right
like that you could even bring this up
how could you do that I want to
understand white rage ridiculous but
that's okay so we've got Brett Bear just
laying out all the people who are now
against him these people were all the
best of the best right when he hired
them these are the best of the best I
only work with the best of the best now
they all turn out to be pigs and morons
and idiots and everything else this is
the guy Millie is the guy that he hired
to be his joint Chief of Staff who's
interested in white rage and is upset
that anyone would even bring up that the
military might have gone woke here's
another doozy from last night bear asked
and this was like a softball man this is
a freaking softball
done pitch yourself to uh to women and
independents why should they vote for
you
and so to the female independent voter
in the suburbs who struggled with family
financing because of inflation she's now
against Biden disapproves of Biden but
wasn't with you in 2020 and so far is a
hard no for you in 2024 but what do you
say to that what do you say to that
female independent Suburban voter who
feels that way to win her back first of
all I won in 2020 by a lot okay let's
get that straight I won in 2020. you
know and if you look at all of the tapes
if you look at everything that you want
to look at you take a look at truth to
vote where they have people stuffing the
ballot boxes on tapes or Mr President
well wait a minute let's go to recent
FBI Twitter let's go to recent the 51
agents all corrupt stuff bro understand
but that's cheating when they lost the
22. okay so you got to understand he's
throwing him a softball here like why
should these women who traditionally
women in Independence
uh Suburban women why who have not
traditionally voted Republican and
certainly did not vote for you we know
that why should they come around to you
this time there's a lot of things that
Trump could say Trump could say Hey you
know DeSantis has gone further right
than me on abortion right he wants six
weeks is now what they have in Florida
that seems extreme to me I know that
most women Suburban women especially
middle-class Suburban women don't feel
it like that would have been an honest
answer like so I'm he could say I'm a
little more moderate on that instead he
gave three well he really gave two
issues he said the election was stolen
okay so I don't know what that has to do
with female and independent voters just
going back to your election with stolen
election was stolen election was stolen
okay the base of the base loves that but
not the people that you need to bring
over the new people and also again if
you believe the election was stolen and
I think there's all sorts of reasons
certainly that we should have always
been allowed to talk about it and
there's all sorts of questions that we
should have about it and everything else
real issue is Donald Trump what have you
done to make sure they will not do it
again and you've done absolutely nothing
that is just the truth so his answer to
what will you do to get middle class
Suburban women to vote for you right the
group that you need more than anything
else his answer was the election was
stolen and look at FBI and Twitter these
things have nothing to do with nothing
the rest of the interview was a lot of
that like it was just bad trust me I
watched it and I was really trying to
find the moments where he was laying out
a vision this is why you should vote for
me this is why I'll do better than to
say this on top of the fact that he
probably created a whole bunch of legal
complications for himself regarding uh
these indictments and everything else
like I cannot imagine if you're in the
midst of these indictments again even if
they're a sham even if there's an
asymmetry all of that stuff it's like
what do you think his lawyers are saying
to him this morning it's very likely
that one of his lawyers will quit even
today because what do you think the
lawyers are trying to put something
together that makes sense here they got
into the classified document stuff he
started talking about how he was he had
mixed his own personal things with the
classified documents like what does that
mean again I'm not Biden did horrible
things with the classified documents and
we need to look at that again I don't
know how many times I can say that sort
of thing but like did Trump have his
baseball glove in with the classified
documents in the sandbox just crazy but
I wanted what I want to do now is I just
want to compare that interview which
happened this week
with an interview a few days ago that
Ron DeSantis did with CBN that's
Christian broadcast network and one of
the questions came up if Trump gets
indicted what would you do as president
what about there's been talk about if
for some reason he was convicted a
potential pardon what a president
DeSantis potentially so I said when I
before that even happened that we have
an uneven justice system we've seen it
weaponized I'm going to end the
weaponization and part of ending the
weaponization is yes we're going to
clean house at FBI Justice can do a lot
but part of it is using your article two
powers to redress wrongs including
potentially Pardons and so we said this
is even before this happened with Trump
you know we'll have people who've been
wronged before we come into office apply
we're going to look if there was a
different standard we're going to be
very inclined to grant clemency in those
situations say guys you know I love the
word juxtaposition but the juxtaposition
of those two guys body language Clarity
competency there's a real irony also
with Trump right now which is that
DeSantis is probably your best chance
possibly your best chance to not end up
in jail he's telling you he's telling
you you'll get the pardon if he's
President right if Biden's president you
ain't getting the pardon and and the
chances that you become president man I
I think they are just sinking and
sinking I the the polls something is not
bearing out properly in the polls and
remember guys National polls mean
nothing right you have to go state by
state and win these primaries uh but
again I don't want to get lost in in the
okay this is what's happening on the
ground here and there I want to really
focus on like what are they really
talking about right now so Trump is
still talking about election
interference Trump is talking about or
he's talking about a stolen election
Beyond election interference he's
talking about how all the people who
used to work for him who were the best
of the best are now pigs and morons
here is uh DeSantis when he was asked
about some of Trump's behaviors and and
why that kind of doesn't work anymore
I appreciate what the former president
has done in a variety of Realms he
opposes that bill he said it was quote
harsh to protect an unborn child when
there's a detectable heartbeat I think
that's Humane to do I think pro-lifers
have been wanting to see you know good
pro-life protections whether it's
Florida or Iowa under Kim Reynolds very
important that you're able to get this
stuff done and of course we have
Universal school choice in Florida we
got that done parents have a right to
direct the education and upbringing of
their kid particularly for parents who
want a religious education they now have
the ability if they can't afford it they
have a scholarship and yes we have
Christian Schools but we have Jewish Day
schools we have things for all parents
that's made our state a lot stronger so
I don't think there's been anyone that's
really been delivering on these key
issues more consistently than me a lot
of times what Republicans and even
conservatives will do they'll say okay
let's just slow the left down a little
bit so it's kind of like manage decline
no no I've reversed the decline and
Florida we're on offense in Florida and
you know what people are responding
positively I think the country is more
prepped right now than ever the majority
to say you know what you know we need to
get behind somebody that's going to
fight back against all this nonsense but
it's going to do it smartly it's going
to be disciplined going to be focused
and is going to actually bring all this
stuff in for a landing and if we can do
half of what we did in Florida up in
Washington we are going to be in really
good shape as a country art disciplined
focused right like is anything that he
said right there did he say anything
right there that was not true
it was all true it's not just that just
that we're slowing it down in Florida we
are actively reversing it by getting
wokeness out of schools by getting ESG
out of our government institutions and
our banks and things of that nature like
we're actually pushing it aside the
manage decline point is interesting my
friend Michael malis who's been on the
show many times he always says that
conservatism is just liberalism at the
speed limit
the santis is proving that that doesn't
have to be the way that you can actually
go on offense and start reversing what
the system is doing ever to everybody uh
but it went on a little bit further I
really thought this might have been the
best portion of that interview
um he was asked DeSantis was asked why
evangelicals should support him in the
race and you have to remember Christian
evangelicals have supported Trump at
record high numbers right it was
something I think it was like over 90
percent uh obviously Mike Pence wants to
get a little bit of that constituency I
just don't think that one's going to
happen but here's DeSantis making his
case for why they should vote for him
Iowa South Carolina two key important
States there's so many important States
but evangelicals play obviously an
outsized role in those States
specifically what's your message to them
and I know it's really to all voters I
get that but but to evangelicals I mean
they're looking at a country that's kind
of hell in a handbasket many others have
as well what is your message to them
because let's be honest in 2016 they
like Donald Trump a lot 2020 they did
too maybe not as much but they still did
why they might still want to go with
Trump but so why you rather than a
Donald Trump who you know was very uh
successful with evangelicals well one I
mean I think in Florida you know we've
taken a purple State turned it into a
red State through bold leadership we
need to do the same thing nationally
we've got to beat Biden the other thing
is I don't think there's any elected
official in the country who's not only
stood up for the values that we all
share but has actually beat the left
back on these things we're winning in
Florida against gender ideology it is
not in our schools I just signed
legislation saying teachers are not
allowed to demand pronouns pounds from
from the from the kids I had Walt Disney
World come down on me and fight me on
that all these other Republicans are
actually taking the side of Disney
they're criticizing me for standing up
to Disney because they're a big powerful
company and all this other stuff we
stood our ground on that and we beat
Disney and signed that into law and we
ended Disney's self-governing status and
I think you know there have been a lot
of Republicans Through The Years you
know who've said they would do things
but when it really gets tough you know
are you able to stand your ground and do
it
again I want to ask you if you're
watching this right now and let's say
you're you're a huge Trump supporter
still
did Rhonda said to say anything that was
untrue there
and the answer is no he did not he's
laying out what he has done and now I
just want to show you one more uh I said
the last one was probably the best one
this is really probably the best one
because what I think we need right now
is we need a renewal of everything right
we need a renewal of our relationship to
government I think we need sort of a
spiritual renewal I think we need a
renewal when it comes to just our uh
how we deal with the media how we deal
with each other like the whole freaking
thing and I think Ron DeSantis
understands that and he understands what
the founders understood and he
understands American philosophy and the
theology that underpinned it and much
more take a look
how do you see the the country from a
judeo-christian standpoint a lot of
people call us a Christian Nation they
don't mean it from a standpoint of
everybody has to be Believers of Christ
obviously that's not what they're
talking about but that this country was
founded on judeo-christian principles
how do you see that in terms of infusing
that into public policy of course it was
I mean I don't think there's any
question about that
um you know this Society a United States
of America you know was built on the
foundation you know of what happened
thousands of years ago in the holy land
and I think the jio Christian values
undergird everything that the founding
fathers did some of it you know was just
so embedded they didn't even need to
think about it of course you know those
are the values that you had so we need
more God in society today no absolutely
I mean look at the end of the day uh
there's certain problems and economic
problems there's there's problems at the
border there's all very important uh but
you know why are we here why are we Free
People we're free because God has
endowed us with inalienable rights
that's why America was founded our
constitution was created not to give us
rights but to protect the rights that
God has already bestowed upon us look
you guys know I like the guy I'm
supporting the guys I'm not I'm not
hiding anything here but that at the end
where he can explain like could Donald
Trump actually explain that why the
Constitution protects our rights and
doesn't give us rights right that's the
point we have inalienable human rights
given to us by God and even if you're
even if you're completely secular the
point is that the government did not
make you free but what the government
can do is protect your freedom freedom
is the is the birthright of being a
human being and the fact that he can
calmly and coolly explain that I think
is just in stark contrast with what I
would say is sort of like the the the
sort of descending kind of craziness
around Donald Trump and that and that is
just a shame he is laying out what his
role would be as the chief executive of
the United States of America and guess
what guys you're not going to believe it
now we'll get into some more fun stuff
the mainstream media is not having it uh
here's a headline from The Washington
Post
as Ron DeSantis pursues the presidency
his wife's role is Limitless Casey 42
isn't a typical political spouse why
does she Inspire so much fear her eyes
in TV and insular marriage tell the
story I have to say Carol Markowitz who
uh you guys know Carol she's been on our
panel shows many time writer for New
York Post and a bunch of other
Publications she I tweeted that article
out and she wrote back I'm going to put
insular marriage in my Twitter by
insular marriage yes so she's married to
one man and she's one chick and they're
married to each other marriage is pretty
good but if you're afraid if you're
afraid of Casey DeSantis do we have uh
do we have the image of Casey where are
we going here are we going with the
Kaylee thing first oh okay so first if
you're afraid of Casey DeSantis well
here this is this past weekend yeah
that's me and Casey hanging out big
smiles that's Steve Cortez right there
that's us having lunch I'm sitting next
to the governor and Casey was just great
you know the kids were there and they're
getting face paint they're eating ice
cream she was asking about our kids I
showed her a bunch of pictures all
smiles like I know this is just
anecdotal but these are just like decent
human beings it's so profoundly
ridiculous like is there someone walking
around go Casey DeSantis like come on
come on but they cannot stop themselves
anyway that Washington Post piece that
we just showed you the Tweet about
uh it was a 5 000 word diatribe it was
completely and utterly ridiculous uh
Kaylee mcenany you know Kaylee used to
work for Donald Trump now Donald Trump
hates her uh she read the entire piece
and she uh summed it up quite eloquently
here on Fox
it's disgusting what they are doing to
the first lady of Florida it is uh she's
Unstoppable she's smart she's strong
she's accomplished and she's
conservative so she will be attacked I
read every word of this hit piece last
night it was in The Washington Post it
was north of 5 000 words uh and the
animating themes were this okay they
loved being around each other Rhonda
Santos and Casey DeSantis they're
private and when he was in Congress he
would leave at if the vote was at noon
he'd be on his way to the airport at
1206 because he wanted to see his family
sounds like a great marriage to me and
then the other complaint about Rhonda
Santos was this there were three things
he liked to talk about with his staff
the Constitution baseball and golf I
mean okay why is this bad so my take
away from this is this is the most
flattering hit piece I have ever read
and is it this is the worst thing they
have on the desantises wow what a great
family uh a role model family Trump is
going to be doubly unhappy with her
today uh but look we've seen this thing
right this is rinse and repeat this is
them lying about Trump all the time and
now they're just moving over to the guy
that they know is the real threat again
Casey DeSantis is a seriously like
lovely decent person I saw them like
playing with the kids and making sure
that her son had the chicken fingers and
then they got ice cream and and Ron went
out of it the governor went out of his
way to give some food off his plate the
kid like it's just it's just so
profoundly ridiculous but the the
corporate press the mainstream media
they cannot stop another person from
Washington Post she's a columnist at the
Washington Post she's also an MSNBC
contributor she pretends to be a
conservative but she's obvious you know
what do I always say it's a pet
conservative they give him a cookie and
then they go home is Jennifer Rubin now
I want to say clearly once again I am in
no way related to this woman I have gone
through the records ancestry.com there
is no connection between Dave Rubin and
Jennifer Rubin I know the internet loves
to say that there is but there isn't
anyway here she is on Ron DeSantis just
ridiculous
do those resources matter Jennifer in
this environment if Ron DeSantis has not
figured out fundamentally how to
distinguish himself from Donald Trump
well you need a candidate first of all
um it's always good to have um troops
and when you train them to do door
knocking of course they can door knock
for anybody after they've learned how to
do it
um but the problem with Rhonda Santos is
Ron DeSantis um he's a thoroughly
unlikable boring thuggish
um bully and uh voters could figure that
out very quickly they have figured it
out so I think the challenge for the
other uh candidates who might actually
have a much better shot against Trump
they should try to push DeSantis out of
the race why don't they try attacking
him they can pick up his votes they can
pick up more of the Trump vote uh not
Trump vote rather
um and then someone one of them can
mount an effective opposition right now
none of them want to attack Trump I
think that's cowardice I think that's
silly but if they don't want to do that
at least go after DeSantis God she is a
vile disgusting woman and she is not my
relative you see when they do that thing
when they accidentally say the quiet
part out loud she knows the sand this is
the threat so she doesn't want any
Republican to win but what she's saying
is could some of those other people that
we know can't win could they do some
stuff that we'd like them to do because
the guy that actually is going to be the
winner here is the one that we're
threatened most by because we don't want
Republicans to win it's just so obvious
and this thing that he's thuggish and
boorish here's a little b-roll of just
when I saw him at the event the other
day like he's just a good dude we
actually did talk about baseball for a
minute we did like he's just nice he's
enjoying himself I told him I think I
said right there you already have my
vote don't worry about it I'm gonna get
out of here you can talk to the other
people
um and then it was just again like we
had lunch there's Casey there's the
event he brings the kids up like there
were thousands of people there the line
was like a mile long it was just a great
day he loves being out there with the
people it's just so it's really weird
man I gotta tell you I don't I'm having
like a visceral reaction to this because
I see how the sausage is made right like
I see it online I'm at these events I
see reality and then I see the way these
these Liars these propagandists that
that's what they are all these people in
corporate press they lie about
absolutely everything and they take the
few good people who are willing to put
their skin in the game the few good
people who will say I will do the thing
that nobody wants to do because it's a
real pain in the ass and they will come
for you and your family and they will
say horrible things about your wife and
your kids and about you and everything
else it's just vile
speaking of vile there's another set of
politicians out there who want to CHOP
Children's genitals off and talk to
young children about sex and gender
those are known as the Democrats here is
Democrat Governor of Maryland Wes Moore
he's very upset that in Florida and
other places we're not letting kids chop
their genitals off and learn about how
to have anal sex weird
why do you think this has become a
passion project of some conservatives I
continue to hearing people making the
argument that we're doing it because we
want to prevent our students from having
discomfort or guilt because we don't
want our students to be able to really
wrestle with these really difficult
things in times when they're maturing as
individuals and difficult historical
points
but the thing I realize and I wanted to
speak out about it is that's actually
not true
it's it's a guys it's not about making
kids uncomfortable it's not about making
kids feel uncomfortable
it's about
telling other kids
that they shouldn't understand their own
power
it's castoring them what
you are the one who wants to castrate
children number one
number two you freaks you weirdos it has
nothing to do with making kids
uncomfortable and guilty it has
everything to do with what is the role
of the state in a child's life and the
role of the state in a child's life in
the same Society a society that we had
for roughly 250 years had nothing to do
with a third grade teacher talking to a
child privately about their genitals for
months calling them uh the opposite sex
name using pronouns and hiding it from
the parents you people are weirdos
what's wrong with you what's wrong with
you really
so then what happens is in Florida a
place like Florida and now what's
happening is happening all over the
country now that blueprint is expanding
it's happening in Iowa you know that
it's happening in Tennessee it's
happening in Montana it's happening in
Texas we are reversing all of this stuff
right not it's exactly what the Santa
said we're not just managing the decline
meaning okay you can kind of do it but
don't talk about it so much we are
actually putting laws in place to get
rid of this nonsense
that's what they're freaking out about
because they want this they want a whole
generation of people to be brainwashed
because that is the only way that at the
end you would vote for a Democrat but
get this this is really wild so this is
space force Lieutenant General her name
is Deanna Bert
she admits here this is absolutely wild
she is admitting that the United States
military now discriminates against
Floridians who want to get into the
military and be involved in space force
and other disciplines because of
desantis's policies on trans kids I mean
this is so bananas wild that I just have
to play it and bash my head against the
table while it's being played
since January of this year more than 400
anti-lgbtq plus laws have been
introduced at the state level
that number is rising and demonstrates a
trend that could be dangerous for
service members their families and the
Readiness of the force as a whole
when I look at potential candidates say
for squadron command I strive to match
the right person to the right job I
consider their job performance and
relevant experience first
however I also look at their personal
circumstances and their family is also
an important factor
it's a good match for a job does not
feel safe being themselves and
performing at their Highest Potential at
a given location
or if their family could be denied
critical Health Care due to the laws in
that state
I am compelled to consider a different
candidate and perhaps less qualified
those barriers are a threat to our
Readiness and they have a direct
correlation to the resiliency and
well-being of our most important
operational Advantage our people is that
unfreaking believable by the way Trump
put that woman in but what she just said
there is we will put less qualified
people in positions of power rather than
putting somebody from the state of
Florida because the State of Florida is
fighting having children's genitals
chopped off that is literally what she
said
and we allow this sort of thing to
happen
but they make up everything right they
make up everything in some ways you
can't blame these people because they
they're under the influence of the Sith
it's something like that nobody knows
what's going on anymore because they've
been so Bamboozled for so long one of
the chief bamboozlers is cringe
Jean-Pierre here she is talking about
how the lgbtqi plus LMNOP Community is
under attack they're attacking them put
up the field
foreign
if by literally lady you mean that the
trans Community is attacking the
lesbians because they're trying to turn
them into men and they're attacking the
bisexuals because they're trying to turn
them whichever way the buys are going
that day or they're trying to turn the
young gay boys into women then yes I
would say that the gays and the L's and
the B's are under attack uh if you mean
anything else beyond that which is
obviously what you actually meant then
you are just a liar and a fraud and a
buffoon nobody's coming for the lesbians
have any could you Google this real
quick have any lesbian rugby leagues and
there's tons of them out there have they
been closed down anywhere are they
coming after the lesbian rugby leagues
are they coming after the gay uh what do
gay guys do in their privacy you know
with other gay guys I don't know like uh
juggling have they come after the gay
jugglers or any of it's just absolutely
insane or line dance no line dancing the
gays line dance that's more of a cowboy
thing I don't know anyway well there's a
lot of gay cowboys too by the way
it's just insane but now if you want to
see something completely insane so Karin
jump here this woman is just incredible
like she makes me think saki was a
decent person
you couldn't have made that up but here
she is uh listen to what she says about
herself this is this is wild go
a year in this role there's been a
couple of things that I that has made me
incredibly proud many things many things
have made me incredibly proud to be at
that Podium during this historic moment
again this is a historic Administration
I'm a historic figure and I certainly
walk in history every day but this is
also a historic making administration
because of this president
she is a historic figure who walks in
history who would say that about
themselves
you're historically dishonest
you are literally awful at your job
your historic figure who walks in
history it's just nonsense oh one more
with her why not
can you respond to governor on sandus in
Iowa today
when Republicans extreme Republicans
these Mega Republicans
don't agree
um with an issue or with policy they
don't bring forth something that's going
to either
have a a good faith conversation they go
to this conversation of woke
but that is not actually policy
but what they what that turns into is
hate
what it turns into is Despicable policy
um and it's just not the way we're going
to move forward
this is not protecting freedoms this is
not having a good faith conversation on
how we can move the country forward this
is about attacking we're talking about
attacking young kids and their parents
because of how they view themselves
because of how they see themselves
because of how they want to live
kids
and their parents
what does that have to do with anything
about being woke that is just hate and
it is uh it is shameful it is shameful
and we're gonna call it out and like I
said the president is going to continue
to say we have the back of the of that
Community or any vulnerable well what an
embarrassingly pathetic diversity hire
she is people really I've said it before
but people should study her years from
now in terms of what hiring somebody
purely based on their sexuality and skin
color uh really results in right they'll
study also doctors who aren't qualified
and pilots who aren't qualified and
everything else everything she said
there was a lie and it's all she can do
all she can do is lie first off she she
Compares DeSantis to an extreme Maga
Republican uh I'm fairly certain that
the Maga Republicans are not thrilled
with Ron DeSantis right now right Maga
and DeSantis are fighting each other
right now that's number one again this
idea that everyone who disagrees with
you is is coming from a place of hate if
you think about remember that video last
week we showed you the parents in
Glendale California the largely Armenian
Community there who were protesting
because they wanted this gender nonsense
out of their schools they didn't want
their Elementary School age kids to be
taught all about this racial nonsense
and the gender stuff and everything else
and then the mainstream media so they
start protesting right they weren't
protesting five years ago it was you
know they didn't know it was happening
in the schools or maybe it wasn't even
happening yet and they were doing just
fine then they push all this stuff on
kids and then parents actually stand up
and fight back and then how does the
mainstream media cover it
anti-lgbtq protesters
verse Pro lgbtq protesters and that
framing that dishonest framing is what
keeps us in this bipolar state that
we're constantly in these are not
anti-lgbt protesters these are called
parents these are parents who just want
their children to be taught math and
history and not be taught about the
genitals of their teacher is that so
much to ask
apparently it is but now what's
interesting here also is that she says
that you know they label everything woke
they everything's woke to them well
there's another guy who's been doing
this again because DeSantis by fighting
wokeness and I can lay it out for you
real quick how he's fought it right we
fought Disney and won we got the gender
stuff out of the schools here in Florida
that ridiculous one AP uh
African-American studies course that was
being taught that was also teaching
genderqueer Theory we got that out we're
pushing ESG out which is a wokeness into
all of our institutions meaning that the
corporations have to start hiring on
diversity and everything else we've
fought all of that here effectively now
we've got cringe on Pierre saying oh
those well you know when you fight woke
you're scary and also here this is from
last week Donald Trump uh doesn't like
the term woke
it's gotten sick and I don't like the
term well because I hear woke woke woke
you know it's like just a term that use
half the people can't even Define it
they don't know what it is what he means
right there is he knows Ron DeSantis is
hitting it home right it's really a it's
really making sense with people it's
reverberating with people when you fight
the woke this idea that people can't uh
Define woke uh is completely ridiculous
woke very simply Equity over equality
equality is the promise of America you
got a chance go get it Equity the
rejiggering of everything especially
when you throw in race and sexuality and
gender that is woke and then it takes
over all of our institutions did I do
that well enough for you I know you get
it you're a Reuben viewer you're wise
but again what it all always comes down
to is maybe a certain set of people
don't vote on policy a certain set of
people don't pay attention to things a
certain set of people just have their
own problems and they're not really that
political or anything else and that by
the way that's what a healthy in a
healthy Society you wouldn't have to be
that political because the things with
the government would be nice and kind of
small and chugging along and it couldn't
screw up too many things and maybe you
couldn't do that do too much but that's
the trade-off right that way you can't
also arrest you and you know keep you in
solitary confinement for the rest of
your life but for all the set of people
that don't pay attention to policies
what I would drive home relentlessly and
I hope that you will drive it home
relentlessly too
is when your your friend who's the lefty
or your cousin who's the Democrat or
whatever and they're screaming about how
evil Florida is and Ron DeSantis is mean
and he's a bully and just say to them
Hey cuz where are people moving to where
are me people moving from and let's look
from Ed wokeness the 2022 migration map
California has lost 343 000 people 2022
this is okay only 2022 we know it's over
a million for Cali probably a million
half Frank Cali since Kobe New York 2022
300 000 down Illinois 142 000 down
Pennsylvania 40 000 down now where are
people going 2022 alone Florida 319 000
in Texas 231 000 in North Carolina a
hundred thousand in South Carolina 84
000 in Tennessee 82 000 in Georgia 81
000 in Arizona
uh 71 000. Arizona is an interesting one
because Arizona has a Democrat Governor
it's Arizona is very very confused for
for a lot of reasons but the point guys
is that people don't like woke wokeness
is the thing we all know it and you can
if you wanna we can Whittle around hell
exactly do you define it but the thing
that we're all always talking about this
endless sexualization this endless hyper
racialization of everything that's what
we Must Destroy one party has wholly
embraced it one party is pretty
half-assed with it but then you've got
one guy who's really fighting it and
that's why everybody's going after him
you might remember this I was in the
room on that night in November of 2022
when we were supposed to get a red wave
and we did not but we did get one
freaking Landslide Victory
record-breaking Victory here in the
State of Florida from that mean bully
who fights against the woke
[Applause]
Freedom we have maintained Law and Order
we have protected the rights of parents
we have respected our taxpayers and we
reject woke ideology
we fight the woke in the legislature we
fight the woke in the schools we fight
the woke and the corporations we will
never ever surrender to the woke mob
Florida is where woke goes to die
yes yes it is I live in Florida where do
you live would you like to join us here
please do we're happy to have you if
you're the same functional human being
and you'd like to not only survive but
dare I quote my last book Thrive right
you can do it if you move to a place
that allows for that so you can see it
guys why is MSNBC why is cringe
Jean-Pierre why is Jen saki Jennifer
Rubin and the rest of those clowns
Rachel Maddow and Chris Hayes and Joy
Reed and all those kinds why are they on
the same side as Donald Trump right now
and even if you put all of that aside
just what we started the show with if
you just look at those two interviews
from the last couple days Donald Trump
name calling everybody uh everyone he's
ever worked with is a and
everything else I didn't hear anything
else about policy you know he did get
into a little bit of the stuff he would
do unfortunately he didn't do any of it
the first time around this is what we
all have to decide this is what we all
have decide I know we got a year and a
half to it I'm not gonna beat everybody
over the head endlessly with the with
the Trump the Santa thing I'm going to
try not to but every now and again I'm
gonna have to check in like we did today
today was a check-in show and and you
have to decide like which one of these
things makes more sense to you which one
of these things actually solves the
problems
it does not have to be like this it has
been like this for too long and it
doesn't have to be like this and I think
there's one guy who can get us out of
this thing and there's one guy who's
going to keep us in this thing
that's my opinion what's yours let us
know in the post game show coming up in
about 30 seconds at
reubenreports.locals.com we leave you
with a cold close remember the last
couple days we've been discussing this
crazy Rogan RFK Peter hotez fight I saw
this this is just a portion right we're
just going to show a portion of it this
is just a portion of this video that I
thought was really hilarious that I saw
online maybe we'll show you the other
half tomorrow so cold close with that
see everybody on the other side adios
one of the things that we're not hearing
a lot about is the unique potential
safety problem of coronavirus vaccines
and then something changed does any
vaccine released by emergency use
authorization by the FDA is an
outstanding vaccine jnj's vaccine has a
risk of life-threatening blood clots
when you hear the beep that's the sound
of safety so don't overthink it uh
they're they're both really good that
they're all really good vaccines get
vaccinated now I gotta call now if you
wait uh it's going to be really too late
to protect your child if this was your
child what happens next could make it
the worst day of your life so even
though covet poses zero threat to
healthy children vaccinate your children
do the right thing be safe and not sorry
I'm strongly recommending for
adolescents to get their two doses of
vaccine are fully immunized after those
two doses advanced technology that can
help save lives this is going to be a
long lasting vaccine a long-lasting
vaccine a few moments later we're seeing
that two doses is not holding up well
for four emergency room visits it's not
holding up well for hospitalizations
everyone's going to need a booster you
need that third immunization triple the
amount get that third immunization the
two mRNA vaccines were always a three
dose vaccine the two mRNA vaccines were
always a three dose vaccine I've always
said this is a three dose vaccine I've
always said this is a three dose vaccine
this is a three dose vaccine but I'm not
done yet that third immunization the
problem is it's not holding up so we may
have to look at sort of innovative
solutions oh God not this again the
fourth immunization just just to keep
them to keep them going keep the country
uh going we have to consider some out of
the box things a fourth immunization
four a fourth immunization get that
second boost a second boost to keep the
country uh going I've made that
recommendation before the immunization
but I'm still not done one semester
later unfortunately the numbers are
starting to Trend up again so the
hospitalizations are up and so the most
important message that I have this
morning is get your new bivalent booster
uh Lillian Lee's saying they got their
booster and I was like oh I need to get
mine and then I found out they they're
talking about the third shot
and is that the bivalent or is it the
fourth booster or does it matter like
don't worry so much about the number
there's no wrong way to use it you have
to get it this new bivalent booster you
can double or triple stack up the new
bivalent one is is doing a much better
job you have to get a booster yeah you
need to get this new bivalent booster
not by valent booster for covet but does
everyone ages 12 and older need a
booster the answer is yes yes and by the
way if you're over 50 and have gotten
two boosters and more than four two or
four two to four months out you're gonna
need a third booster as well a fifth
immunization five I don't think we're
gonna need an annual booster like flu
eventually doctor Hotes supports yearly
boosters just like blue but I'm still
not done it looks as though the boosters
are not holding up quite as well as we'd
like um and and and I think our think
thinking is going to change and that
what's going to happen is every you know
few months we may need another booster
[Music]
thank you
foreign